Depuis quelques dimanches, nous sommes en train de méditer dans la conclusion de la lettre de Paul au Galacte.
Cette lettre qui est considérée l'une des plus importantes non seulement pour l'émancipation du christianisme par rapport au judaïsme.
Quelque part c'est plutôt le judaïsme qui est à service du christianisme qui est l'inverse.
Et il y avait cette menace à la genèse de l'église sous la pression ou l'épression politique qui voulait que le christianisme soit vu comme une espèce de ramification du christianisme.
Notamment cette église qui était l'une des églises qui ont eu les plus beaux commencements, l'église en Galatie, implantée par l'apôtre Paul lui-même.
Même si elle a eu un très beau commencement en ayant reçu l'évangile du christ indépendamment de leur arrière-plan juif car ils étaient païens.
C'était une église qui a souffert avec l'infiltration des hypocrites religieux, des personnes qui s'est réclamées chrétiennes mais qui étaient encore sous les systèmes légalistes judaïsants.
Et donc ils ont quelque part, ils étaient en train de jouer pour dérober les Galates de leur vraie liberté.
Ils étaient en train de donner la sensation à ces hommes que comme ils n'étaient pas les descendants ethniques des juifs
ou comme ils n'étaient pas en train de pratiquer les mêmes rites religieux que les juifs.
C'est comme s'ils étaient en deuxième rang des chrétiens.
Les chrétiens les plus importants c'était ceux qui étaient non seulement en train de professer la foi en Jésus
mais qui étaient en train de professer la foi en Jésus plus être sous la gouvernance des Moïse ou les systèmes religieux juifs.
Ils voulaient surtout circoncire les Galates.
Ils voulaient que les Galates gardent certaines dates
et ils voulaient que les Galates aussi se soumettent à une espèce de régime alimentaire sélectionné pour les juifs.
Et donc l'apôtre Paul, il va délivrer le christianisme de cette notion d'être une ramification sous le judaïsme
mais il va aussi à travers cela protéger la vraie conception de la foi chrétienne
en nettoyant l'évangile de l'un des plus grands risques qu'on puisse voir, les risques du légalisme.
C'est-à-dire ces hommes ont été convertis et en étant Jésus-Christ indépendamment de leur connaissance de l'Ancien Testament
ils étaient convertis par la contemplation de la loi incarnée Christ lui-même
ils ont expérimenté les pardons malgré leur arrière-plan très paillant, très charnel, très idolâtre
et ils étaient convaincus qu'ils étaient des vrais enfants des dieux adoptés par Christ.
Ils ont expérimenté une espèce de sanctification explosive dans leur début de la foi
indépendamment de leur connaissance des pratiques religieuses de l'Ancien Testament.
Mais là ils étaient sous les risques et sous la menace de se faire circoncire et de perdre leur liberté.
Donc l'apôtre Paul va conclure la lettre en apportant un rappel des principaux enjeux
et il fait dans cette conclusion une conclusion qui est plutôt une espèce de sommation.
en ayant présenté l'évangile dans sa clarté, en ayant présenté comment les chrétiens vivent
non seulement les pardons mais la sanctification qui sont inséparables dans cette œuvre de rédemption du Christ
et la manière dont, en Jésus seul, nous sommes les vrais enfants des dieux
et nous ne pouvons plus jamais mêler en relation avec Dieu, néovrotis,
comme si Dieu était en train de nous menacer pour perdre notre statut en tant qu'enfant.
L'apôtre Paul, en mettant en phase tous ces enjeux qu'on pourrait perdre,
les vrais évangiles et la vraie réjouissance de la vraie liberté chrétienne,
il va faire cette sommation en disant « on ne se moque pas des dieux »
et c'est comme s'il disait vers la fin de cette lettre,
maintenant, soit vous vous éloignez, vous vous écartez de cette mauvaise influence
pour que vous soyez véritablement considérés comme des vrais chrétiens,
soit vous êtes en train de vous découper, vous priver de la grâce de Dieu, du vrai évangile.
« Christ n'a plus aucune utilité pour vous si vous vous soumettez à cette influence. »
Donc cette conclusion est une sommation,
car il va présenter un contraste entre les vrais chrétiens
et les vrais modèles du christianisme d'un côté
et de l'autre côté, ces imposteurs.
Et par la présentation de ces deux archétypes,
il veut que cette Église prenne une position, une résolution.
« Nous allons nous soumettre et suivre les modèles de l'apôtre Paul
et des croyants qui mènent la foi comme l'apôtre Paul,
soit ils vont décider de se soumettre aux influences judaïsantes. »
Et à partir de là, la lettre finit dans un suspense,
car dans cette lettre, l'apôtre Paul ne donne que des bénédictions conditionnelles,
comme si cette Église était encore sous une espèce de discipline.
Il n'y a pas de manifestation dans cette conclusion,
des réjouissances de l'apôtre Paul par rapport à ces personnes.
Il n'y a pas de projet futur, de travail ensemble.
C'est comme si cette Église était réservée dans un suspens, sous-discipline,
dont la réconciliation ou la continuité de cette marche ensemble
dépendrait de la résolution de cette Église,
de suivre la bonne direction.
Donc c'est une conclusion assez dure, assez exhortative,
et Paul finit pour manifester ces contrastes.
Donc au verset 12, il dit « Tous ceux qui veulent se rendre agréables selon la chair, »
Donc la question parle des judaïsants,
mais parle aussi des personnes qui se laissent influencer par les judaïsants.
Si vous voulez mener la foi de cette manière,
c'est car vous voulez vous-même être au contrôle des choses,
et par là, vous êtes en train de vouloir être agréables selon la chair,
faire osage de la religion pour gagner de la faveur humaine.
Et au verset 14, il dit « Pour ceux qui me concernent… »
Donc à la fin des comptes, les contrastes, c'est l'apôtre Paul qui dit « Voici les mauvais modèles,
voici comment je marche, et c'est mieux si vous choisissez de marcher de cette manière. »
Et au verset 14 plus tard, il dit aussi « Loin de moi la pensée de me glorifier d'autres choses
qui est la croix de notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
par qui le monde est crucifié pour moi, comme je suis pour le monde. »
Donc là, l'apôtre Paul est en train de manifester qu'à la fin des comptes,
la manière la plus évidente, la plus radicale d'identifier un vrai chrétien,
c'est là où on voit une personne qui n'a même pas la pensée de se glorifier
en autre chose qui est dans la croix du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Ce n'est pas même qu'il y ait dans une conception légère ou superficielle du Seigneur Jésus,
c'est spécifiquement dans la croix du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
qui parle d'une identité qui nous humilie,
mais qui parle aussi de quelque chose qui va toujours accompagner les vrais évangiles,
la persécution, la perte des privilèges, les menaces.
Et donc, ce n'est pas non seulement quelque chose par rapport auquel on pourrait vouloir éviter,
mais c'est quelque chose en quoi nous devrions exclusivement nous glorifier, nous réjouir.
Là où cette réalité n'est pas présente, la vraie conversion n'est pas présente.
Et donc l'apôtre Paul est en train de présenter à la fin des comptes
ces contrastes pour qu'on puisse s'examiner
et avoir une espèce de résolution déterminée à vivre à la hauteur de cette réalité.
Les verset 15 qui démontrent aussi une autre réalité,
si on peut dire que les verset 14 manifestent de manière observable
comment la personnelle vit,
les verset 15, ils démontrent comment cette réalité a lieu.
« Car ce n'est rien que d'être circoncis ou encirconcis,
ce qui est quelque chose, c'est d'être une nouvelle créature. »
C'est-à-dire, vous pouvez beau faire des efforts
pour chercher à vivre comme si vous étiez chrétien,
mais en réalité, seuls sont les chrétiens ceux qui sont nés de nouveau
par l'œuvre du Saint-Esprit,
et leur vie va se manifester par ne pas se glorifier
à aucune autre chose que dans la croix du Saint-Jésus-Christ.
Donc nous sommes ici devant les minimums dénominateurs communs
qui déterminent la vraie foi, la foi authentique.
Donc la vérité centrale,
c'est que les tests ultimes de la réalité de la nouvelle création
sont une vie qui se glorifie exclusivement dans la croix de notre Saint-Jésus-Christ.
C'est les versets contrôlateurs de tous ces passages
et la question clé qu'on a posée,
c'est quelles sont les preuves d'une vie
qui se glorifie exclusivement en Jésus-Christ
par opposition à l'hypocrisie religieuse,
un rapport utilitaire à la foi.
On a considéré déjà trois réponses.
La première, basée sur les versets 11,
lorsqu'il a pour trépaule dit
« Voyez avec quelles grandes lettres je vous écris de ma proprement. »
Et donc là, on voit qu'il y a des signes authentiques,
constants et proportionnels des vraies affections religieuses.
Donc une vie qui se glorifie réellement dans la croix
manifeste une affection authentique pour Christ,
son évangile et son peuple,
plutôt qu'un faux soin intéressé.
Ces autres imposteurs,
ils vous donnent l'impression qu'ils sont préoccupés avec vous,
mais ils veulent vous exploiter.
Et ils peuvent même manifester des affections,
mais ces affections sont incohérentes avec la croix
et les scandales de la croix du Christ.
Donc on a beau méditer sur ces versets
et sur ces vérités.
La deuxième réponse,
la deuxième preuve,
c'est qu'une vie qui se glorifie réellement dans la croix
promeut la liberté par les dons de soi
plutôt que l'autopréservation manipulatrice.
C'est-à-dire, verset 12,
« Tous ceux qui veulent se rendre agréables selon la chair
vous contraignent à vous faire circoncire. »
Donc d'un côté,
c'est une espèce de manipulation,
car c'est par contrainte,
c'est par insistante
que ces personnes-là arrivent
à vous conduire à un comportement légaliste
qui va à l'encontre de la liberté chrétienne.
Donc, pour la liberté,
Christ nous a affranchis,
c'est-à-dire,
les désirs de se sanctifier pour les chrétiens
sont un désir naturel
de la nouvelle créature.
Il n'est pas motivé par les menaces.
Il est motivé par les désirs
de plaire le cœur du Père
qui a manifesté son amour
en nous affranchissant
non seulement de la coupabilité du péché,
mais aussi de la pollution
et de la puissance du péché.
Et donc,
d'un côté,
l'apôtre Paul est en train de donner sa propre vie,
de prendre des risques.
La première fois,
il s'est présenté au Galate,
il était presque mort
en ayant été lapidé
dans la ville voisine.
Et à partir de là,
l'apôtre Paul,
il est encore en train de donner sa vie
dans les champs missionnaires
en écrivant cette lettre
et donc en s'exposant
à la persécution
de cette pression juive
de laquelle
les judaïsans veulent échapper.
Et donc, il dit,
l'apôtre Paul dans ses versets,
il vous constreigne
à vous faire séconcire
uniquement
afin de n'être pas persécuté
pour la croix de Christ.
Et donc,
l'imposteur,
celui qui n'est pas chrétien,
il peut professer être chrétien,
mais sa vie sera caractérisée
pour cacher un peu
l'aspect scandaleux
de la croix,
l'aspect qui pourrait
provoquer de la persécution,
qui pourrait nous faire risquer
de perdre l'emploi
si par exemple,
on voulait partager l'évangile
au travail.
Et donc,
l'imposteur,
il est toujours en cachette
pour tout ce qui pourrait
concerner
les risques
qu'on pourrait prendre
dans ce monde.
Et donc,
c'est une autre préservation
manipulatrice,
mais ceux qui veulent,
qui vivent vraiment,
qui s'églorifient vraiment
dans la croix,
ils prennent les risques,
ils donnent leur vie,
ils font les dons de soi
afin de promouvoir
la vraie liberté,
les vrais saluts des perdus.
La troisième vérité
qu'on a considérée,
c'est qu'une vie
qui s'églorifie réellement
dans la croix
promeut la sainteté
par une piété sincère
plutôt qu'une religion utilitaire
par une impiété cachée.
Et donc,
les circoncis,
verset 13,
eux-mêmes,
n'observent point la loi,
mais ils veulent
que vous soyez circoncis
pour se glorifier
dans votre chair.
Donc,
ce sont ceux
qui vont vouloir
baptiser les personnes
parfois de manière irresponsable,
juste pour pouvoir
présenter
combien de personnes
ont été converties
ou qui vont faire
les appels
à l'hôtel
de manière très manipulatrice,
parfois en utilisant
même
les pionnots
ou la musique,
vers la fin du serment
pour jouer un peu
avec les émotions,
faire les personnes
répéter certaines prières
juste pour pouvoir dire
combien de personnes
ont accepté
les Christs
à la fin du culte.
Et donc,
ça,
c'est juste un exemple,
ce n'est pas toujours
corrompu,
la manière dont ils font,
les motivations,
mais c'est juste pour montrer
que cette insistance
des judaïsants
qui voulaient circoncier
ces personnes,
leur intérêt,
c'était les avantages
et les bénéfices
qu'ils auraient
à travers
les résultats
de cette mission,
d'être vus
par ceux qui étaient
dans les pouvoirs politiques
comme des personnes
qui pourraient recevoir
des avantages.
Et donc,
l'intérêt,
que ce soit
par l'exploit
des fidèles
ou par les privilèges
qu'ils pourraient avoir
devant les plus importants,
ces personnes-là,
les imposteurs,
ils ne sont pas du tout
en train d'obéir la loi,
ils n'emmènent pas
une vie de piété,
ils sont dans la débauche
en cachette,
mais dans la réalité,
ils donnent l'impression
d'être sans
juste pour gagner
des bénéfices.
Et de l'autre côté,
c'est par les modèles,
c'est par la vie
de sainteté
et par une piété sincère
que l'apôtre Paul
était en train
de promouvoir
la sainteté
du peuple
sans avoir
une relation utilitaire
mais risquant tout
pour promouvoir
leur sainteté.
Et donc,
on a traité
ces trois vérités
et aujourd'hui,
nous allons traiter
une nouvelle
et je vous invite
à relire
les versets 14
qui est
les versets clés
de tous ces passages.
Donc,
à partir du moment
où l'apôtre Paul
dit
« Pour ce qui me concerne,
son intérêt,
c'est d'établir
un contraste
évident
entre les imposteurs
! »
et les modèles
du vrai christianisme.
Et donc,
nous avons besoin
que les christianismes
soient non seulement
prêchés
avec fidélité,
mais il a plu
à Dieu
que l'Église
soit motivée
par les monuments
vivants
de l'œuvre
rédemptrice.
Et donc,
c'est important pour nous
d'avoir des répères.
Et dans la plupart des cas,
la mauvaise santé
des Églises
est liée
au manque
des répères,
des personnes fidèles.
Et des fois,
on contemple
l'Église
dans sa situation
corrompue,
malade,
et on se dit
« Comme les choses
fonctionnent comme ça,
c'est comme ça
que les choses
doivent fonctionner. »
On a une tendance
à accepter
au lieu de revenir
à la parole de Dieu
pour trouver
les vrais répères
et au lieu de revenir
dans l'histoire
d'autres siècles
pour voir des bons répères.
Et donc,
des fois,
nos meilleurs amis
et nos pères spirituels
devraient être retrouvés
plutôt dans d'autres siècles
que dans les nôtres.
Et par la grâce de Dieu,
dans toutes les générations,
nous avons quand même
des bons répères.
Et donc,
l'apôtre Paul,
il dit
« Pour ce qui me concerne,
loin de moi la pensée
de me glorifier
d'autres choses
que dans la croix
de notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ
par qui le monde
est crucifié pour moi
et moi,
je le suis pour le monde. »
Et c'est ici
que tous les pasteurs
deviennent impotents.
Donc,
des fois,
on nous demande
« Quel courage tu as
de toucher à certains points
qui vont confronter
le monde, etc. »
et à chaque fois,
on dit
« Non, ce n'est pas
une question de courage,
c'est une question
de crainte. »
Car on sait
que c'est mieux
de craindre
les seigneurs
de l'univers
qui un jour
va juger les morts
et les vivants
que de craindre
les peuples,
les personnes.
On ne peut pas,
ce n'est pas intelligent,
c'est fou
de craindre
plus l'épée
que l'enfer.
Vous comprenez ?
Mais,
ce n'est pas tout simplement
quand on est en train
de confronter
les péchés
les petits péchés
domestiqués
des personnes
au sein de l'Église.
Mais c'est surtout,
à mon avis,
la chose la plus difficile
pour un prédicateur,
ce n'est pas si tant
de ne pas être
à la hauteur
de la confrontation
de la chair humaine.
C'est surtout
de ne pas être
à la hauteur
de la beauté
de la gloire du Christ.
C'est là
où on doit craindre
le plus
de ne pas faire honneur
à la gloire
de l'Évangile.
Qui est suffisant
pour ces choses ?
Et c'est devant
ce type de passage
où tous les prédicateurs
sont avec une pensée
et un cœur partagé,
la bouche qui parle
et l'esprit qui prie
sans cesse.
Un homme des dieux
qui est en train de dire
qu'il abrore même
la moindre possibilité
de penser
à se glorifier
à une autre chose
que la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ.
Et donc,
nous allons considérer
ces passages
en suppliant Dieu
de nous donner
de la grâce
pour être à la hauteur
avec nos faiblesses
de la gloire
de ces versets.
Et c'est étonnant.
Donc ici,
nous sommes devant
un apôtre Paul
qui est en train
de laisser clair
en fait les risques
qui peuvent frapper
à la porte
de plusieurs hommes
qui peuvent chercher
dans l'Église
une manière
de se glorifier.
De chercher
dans la religion
une manière
de ne pas
se glorifier en Christ.
De faire usage
du nom de Christ
pour trouver
une autre sorte
des gloires.
Par exemple,
des hommes
qui peuvent
étudier
et passer
de degré
en degré.
Donc,
une exhortation
que la prôtre,
pardon,
une exhortation
que Poirachère a faite
dans cette conférence
missionnaire,
c'était de voir
comment aujourd'hui,
il l'a dit,
dans mon passé,
mes repères
des prédicateurs,
c'était ceux
qui prêchaient
jusqu'à ce que.
Ils prêchaient,
ils prêchaient
jusqu'à ce que
quelque chose
se passe.
Ils priaient,
ils priaient
et ils priaient
jusqu'à ce que
quelque chose
se passe.
Jusqu'à ce que
les Saint-Esprit
nous visitent
avec quelque chose
de perceptible
qui a lieu.
On prêche
avec instance
jusqu'à ce qu'on voit
véritablement
les résultats
de la compagnie
des dieux
dans la prédication
et qu'il est parti
donc en mission
et quand il est rentré,
tout était à propos
des prêchers
correctement,
avec une structure
des sermons
qui puisse être
perçue
par les professeurs
comme un bon serment.
Et il dit
qu'aujourd'hui,
pour certains,
c'est de passer
de l'université,
pardon,
de l'école
au séminaire
du séminaire
au master,
du master au doctorat
et du doctorat
au podcast.
Et de voir
que des fois,
certaines personnes
s'accrochent
à leur titre.
Ils vont même
réclamer
être traités
comme docteurs.
C'est une chose
pour nous
de savoir apprécier
et de,
voilà,
honorer les choses.
Mais quand on va
à l'apôtre Paul,
loin de moi,
la pensée
de me glorifier
à aucune autre chose
qui est dans la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ.
Paul,
qui n'a pas eu
de dégrés
académiques,
théologiques,
qui a fait
la meilleure théologie
dans les champs missionnaires,
qui s'est présenté
comme,
avant
de savoir reconnaître
qu'il a été
commissionné
en tant qu'apôtre,
il s'est présenté
comme serviteur,
esclave
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
de la croix
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Ce n'est pas
pour ne pas
savoir reconnaître
que Dieu
a aussi
donné la vocation
à certains
pour être
comme des docteurs,
pour nous aider
à comprendre
la théologie,
mais c'est
de nous rappeler
qu'il y a avant
tout titre
qu'on puisse
associer à nos vies.
Les premiers,
ce sont ceux
qui ont été humiliés
par la croix du Christ,
ceux qui s'églorifient
exclusivement
à la croix du Christ.
Un jeune homme
m'a posé
une question
pendant cette conférence
qui était
la manifestation
d'un cœur humble
et d'un cœur
qui a du zèle.
Et la question
qu'il m'a posée,
c'est
en étant si proche
et intime
d'une personne
qui est si
sollicitée
et attirante
et en évidence,
comment je gère
l'orgueil
dans mon cœur.
Car il s'imaginait
que s'il était
dans ce type
de privilège,
il pourrait être tenté
à se sentir orgueilleux.
Il m'a dit,
je pensais que
quand j'ai vu
qu'il avait
ce niveau d'intimité
avec cette personne,
je pensais que
tu serais dans la première ligne
là en écoutant
sa prédication.
Et ce qui est venu
dans mon cœur,
c'est notamment
quelque chose
lié à ce passage,
c'est que
comment pourrions-nous
considérer
comme un privilège
si dangereux
d'avoir la proximité
avec un grand nombre
de dieux
si nous avons tous,
tous les chrétiens,
le privilège
d'avoir l'amitié
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
le même.
Ce n'est pas
pour ne pas reconnaître
l'essence
des privilèges
de pouvoir
avoir les relations
avec des hommes
des dieux
fidèles.
Mais c'est pour nous rappeler
en fait
que comme
Poachère lui dit
lui-même,
il n'y a pas
de grands hommes
des dieux.
Il y a tout simplement
des hommes
qui connaissent
leur humiliation,
leur humilité
devant la croix
et qui ont un dieu
qui est très grand.
Mais ces risques,
il existe
et l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de se confronter
avec ces personnes
qui font
intentionnellement
du réseautage,
qui font
intentionnellement
de la politique,
qui veulent se placer
en position d'évidence,
qui veulent se glorifier
d'autres choses
qu'à la croix
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Donc la vérité
pour nous aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'une vie
qui se glorifie
réellement dans la croix
démontre une dévotion
exclusive
à la personne
et à l'œuvre
de Jésus-Christ
plutôt qu'une profession
des fois étouffée
par l'amour du monde.
Verset 13 vers la fin,
eux, les imposteurs,
ils veulent
que vous soyez
surconscient
pour se glorifier
dans votre chair.
Pour ce qui me concerne,
loin de moi,
la pensée
de me glorifier
d'autres choses
qui sont dans la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ,
par qui les mondes
sont crucifiés pour moi
comme je les suis
pour les mondes.
La manière intentionnelle
dont l'apôtre Paul
va confronter
ces glorifiés
exclusivement en Christ
et l'amour du monde
montre clairement
que la vraie profession
des fois,
la seule foi authentique,
elle n'est pas partagée.
Comme dans la parabole
des terres,
notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ
lui-même nous a enseigné
que parfois,
nous pouvons voir
les personnes
qui peuvent les plus
nous tromper
car c'est facile
quand on voit
des personnes
qui ont déjà été exposées
à une ou deux prédications
de l'évangile
mais qui n'ont pas donné
trop l'écoute
et qui partent.
Donc ça,
ce sont les séances
tombées à côté du schéma,
dans la partie dure
du schéma.
Et Satan vient,
il dérobe
et il part.
Après,
il y a certains
qu'on va voir
qui peuvent manifester
un émotionnalisme
très vite
mais qui très vite aussi
devant les premières difficultés
vont partir de l'église.
C'est les terrains
pireux.
Ok ?
Par contre,
ceux qui seront
les plus capables
de nous tromper,
ce sont ceux
dont la sémence
tombe
entre les épines.
Vous vous rappelez
de la parabole ?
Quel est le problème
de ces cœurs ?
Donc le premier,
il était impénétrable.
Le deuxième,
il était très superficiel
mais n'a pas créé
des racines.
Le troisième,
on a l'impression
que les racines
étaient en train
d'être créées
mais la dispute
souterrain,
pas dans la surface,
pas dans les visibles,
mais la dispute
du terrain
à l'intérieur,
les terrains
n'étaient pas nettoyés.
Le cœur
était occupé
par la passion
avec ces mondes
ou les passions
ou l'amour
du monde.
L'autopréservation,
l'autopromotion
et c'est
les deux choses
qui sont affichées
dans la description
de ces passages.
Eux,
ils veulent
que vous soyez
circoncis,
ils veulent avoir
une espèce
de contrôle
sur votre foi,
sur votre religion
afin de se glorifier
dans votre chair.
d'un côté,
c'était
ne pas être
persécutés,
donc ils sont
très préoccupés
à ne pas souffrir
les malheurs
que notre association
en la croix
peut apporter
à nos vies
et de l'autre côté,
ils veulent réjouir
du confort
que ces mondes
peuvent offrir.
Donc la réalité,
c'est l'autopréservation
d'un côté
par la politique,
l'autopromotion
par l'exploit
des fidèles
en voulant
avoir par la religion
une réputation
qui puisse réjouir
des bénéfices.
Et Paul va présenter
les contrastes
avec la croix
du Christ.
Donc notamment
la croix ici
représentant
non seulement
la souffrance
du Christ
qui nous a sauvés,
mais la caractéristique
de notre foi
qui va toujours
nous accompagner
dans un monde
rébelle
et hostile
à Dieu
et à la piété.
Et voilà pourquoi
au verset 14
de l'apôtre Paul
il dit
« Pour ce qui me concerne,
louons-les-moi
à la pensée
de me glorifier
d'autres choses. »
Donc vous êtes avec moi ?
Ce n'est pas suffisant
de dire
« Christ est mon tout
et mon souverain bien
si juste ensuite
presque à la même
hauteur de plaisir
que nous disons
prendre en Christ,
il y a les plaisirs
des attraits
de ces mondes.
Il y a quelque chose
qui puisse nous faire
réjouir
des choses par rapport
auxquelles
quand on parle
et dans l'organisation
de nos vies
sonnent comme
si elles avaient
la même capacité
de nous porter
de la régresses,
parfois même plus
que les Christ,
que quand on parle
du Christ.
des choses
avec qui on passe
plus de temps,
on s'efforce plus
pour réjouir
de ces choses
plutôt
que réjouir
du Christ.
Des choses
autres
que Christ
dans lesquelles
on puisse
se glorifier.
C'est une chose
de se glorifier
avec Christ
des choses
que Christ
nous bénit
mais ça ne fait
qu'à renforcer
la gloire
du Christ
pour nous.
Et donc,
l'apôtre Paul
dit
si autre chose
a un attrait
qui puisse
rivaliser
avec la gloire
de la croix
du Christ,
nous devrions
mettre en question
l'authenticité
de notre salut.
La foi authentique,
elle est
par nécessité
exclusive.
Elle ne peut pas
être considérée
comme quelque chose
que je rajoute
comme une couche
dans ma vie.
Quand on va
se présenter
ou la manière
dont on a
la perception
de nous-mêmes,
quelles sont
les choses
qui déterminent
le plus
notre identité ?
Quelles sont
les choses
dont on parle
le plus
quand on parle
de nous-mêmes ?
Donc,
Jésus
doit être
sanctifié
dans mon cœur,
dans son trône
absolu.
Il doit être
mon seul bien,
comme l'Epsomiste
nous dit.
Même si,
en étant
notre seul bien,
Dieu peut
rajouter
des bonnes choses
dans nos vies,
il est la source
de tous les biens
et les biens
souverains.
C'est-à-dire,
même les choses
qu'on doit chercher
avec diligence
par rapport
à nos vies,
doit être
toujours
vu et perçu
non seulement
comme les fruits
de nos efforts
ou les œuvres
de nos moments,
mais comme la grâce
de Dieu
qui pourvoit.
Chercher Dieu
exclusivement
et à travers Dieu
savoir et connaître
que c'est lui-même
qui pourvoit
toutes les choses.
Donc,
ni Jésus
moins la croix,
c'était la première
reproche de l'apôtre Paul
quand il a dit
qu'ils ne veulent pas
être persécutés,
c'est cette foi
d'imposteur
qui veut Jésus
moins la croix.
C'est clair ?
C'est-à-dire,
je veux me présenter
comme un chrétien
mais dès qu'il est risque
de mon association
à Christ frapper
à la porte,
je cache mon identité.
Donc,
ça,
ce n'est pas la vraie foi,
c'est une foi
de Jésus
moins la croix.
Par contre,
les points ici,
c'est
il ne suffit pas non plus
Jésus plus quelque chose.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Ni Jésus moins la croix,
ni Jésus plus
d'autres bénéfices
qu'on pourrait
s'accrocher
dans cette vie.
Les avantages
de la vraie religion
retombent naturellement.
C'est-à-dire,
Dieu dans sa grâce
peut apporter
beaucoup de bénéfices.
Donc,
un homme qui s'est converti,
il peut devenir
plus diligent,
plus excellent,
travailler avec
beaucoup plus d'honnêteté,
travailler pour Christ,
donc en faisant
toutes les choses
avec excellence
pour la gloire de Dieu.
Il devrait être
les mieux modèles
à son travail.
Sa réputation
en tant qu'homme
ou femme
des familles
va aussi être perçue
comme quelque chose
de beaucoup plus appréciable,
ça devrait être comme ça,
et ces choses
peuvent ouvrir
plus des portes
dans la société.
Mais le fait
qu'on soit associé
à Christ
et au Christ
de la croix,
plus tôt ou plus tard,
vont provoquer
de la persécution.
Et donc,
nous pouvons réjouir
des bénéfices
que Dieu peut apporter
dans nos vies
qui peuvent être
même la conséquence
de la vraie religion,
de la vraie foi,
d'un caractère
sanctifié.
Mais en même temps,
nous devons
toujours nous accrocher
à toutes les choses
de ce monde
avec une prise lâche.
Savoir
que ces moments
temporaires
de réjouissance
des bonnes choses
peuvent disparaître
à n'importe quel moment.
et que lorsque
nous ne pouvons pas
nous taire
pour professer
notre foi
et partager
les bons témoignages,
qu'on sache
que nous devons
ouvrir les mains
si ces choses
nous seront dérobées.
La croix
n'est pas
sous contrôle.
C'est-à-dire,
l'évangile
de la croix,
elle n'est pas
sous contrôle
comme
les imposteurs
veulent le faire.
Donc,
menace
à méconfort ici,
difficulté
pour mon autre
promotion ici,
je cache ma foi,
je contrôle
la croix
et j'essaie
de diminuer
son impact
scandaleux.
La persécution
qui découle
de la croix
du Christ
n'est pas
une question
de quantification.
Ce n'est pas
à nous
de calculer
quand est-ce
que la persécution
sera déclenché.
C'est une question
d'identité.
La croix
pour nous
n'est pas
tout simplement
la représentation
des conséquences
des persécutions
qui viendront
sur nous.
La croix
pour nous
c'est une question
d'identité.
Si j'ai connu
l'évangile,
si j'ai vraiment
compris l'évangile,
cette croix
qui est associée
par des saints
divants
à l'évangile
du Seigneur
Jésus Christ,
c'est la croix
qui doit
devenir
mon identité.
Moi,
j'ai déviant
cet scandale,
la représentation
de cet scandale.
Donc,
c'est impossible
de désassocier
dans le vrai chrétien
les scandales.
Tous ceux
qui veulent mener
une vie pieuse
seront persécutés.
et les versets
continuent en disant
de me glorifier
à aucune autre chose
qu'est la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
par qui le monde
est crucifié
pour moi
comme je le suis
pour le monde.
c'est-à-dire
que cet amour
réciproque
dans ma relation
avec le monde
il est
disparu.
Donc,
cette foi
qui est étouffée
par l'amour
du monde,
c'est une foi
où
les attraits
du monde
peuvent
rivaliser
avec
la direction
et l'identité
du Christ.
est-ce que je suis
complètement
rassuré
de ma valeur ?
Est-ce que je suis
complètement rassuré
d'une espèce
d'estime
de moi-même
indépendamment
de ma position
sociale
ou des circonstances
de vie
que je traverse
car je suis associé
au Christ
et la croix.
c'est Christ
qui
m'a réconcilié
par mérite
avec Dieu.
Est-ce que c'est Dieu
qui me regarde
aujourd'hui
comme en étant
parfaitement
sanctifié ?
La personne
par rapport
à qui
ou
de qui
la vie
à propos de moi
est plus importante
que la vie
de n'importe
quelle autre personne
dans ce monde.
si pour Dieu
je suis
complètement
acceptable,
mon identité
est associée
à celle
du Christ.
Comment
pourrais-je
souffrir
des manques
d'assurance
de soi,
des doutes,
des crises
d'identité,
des valeurs
en méjugeant
par les mêmes règles
ou mesures
que les mondes
cherchent
de méjuger ?
Donc,
les imposteurs
lorsqu'ils vont
se présenter
sont toujours
préoccupés
aux paramètres
mondants
pour se présenter
créés
par
les systèmes
qui essayent
de créer
des démons
dans nous
pour acheter
des choses
que si nous n'arrivons
pas à avoir,
on peut vivre
très bien
sans ces choses-là.
Et on est toujours
à la recherche
de ces choses
où la position
ou un degré,
on ne sait pas bien
si on ne peut pas
se présenter
comme ça.
Donc,
il y a cette attirance
du monde
qui rivalise
avec la foi
soi-disant chrétienne.
Donc,
une personne
par rapport
à qui
la vie
ne semble pas être
une vie marquée
comme si
elle était
crucifiée
pour le monde.
Son manque
de contentement
ne passe pas
par les manques
de la piété
ou même
du paradis
qui nous est réservé
ou de l'accès
à la présence
de Dieu,
la communion
avec Christ
et leur manque
de réconfort
mondant
ou le désir
d'avoir des choses
qu'on n'a pas encore
semble gêner
beaucoup
la vie
de ces personnes-là.
À chaque fois
qu'une tentation
à se conformer
au monde
frappe à la porte
de cette personne,
elle semble
cacher
ses obligations
et ses devoirs
en tant que chrétien.
Ça peut être
des choses
qui sont évidemment
des sous tristes
dans ce monde
mais des fois
même des bonnes choses
qui sont
imprégnées
du malin
et qui cherchent
à prendre
la place
des dieux.
La piété
en constante,
ça peut être
l'argent
pour suivre
une relation
avec un non-chrétien
ou une non-chrétienne,
ça peut être
la fête,
les débauches,
les manques
de modération,
les divertissements,
l'anxiété
exagérée,
la réputation,
les amitiés,
les hobbies,
la planification
exagérée
des renoncements
trop calculés
qu'on puisse faire.
Laisse-moi d'abord
enterrer mon père
et après je viens
te suivre.
Si j'avais
l'argent
que cette personne a,
je serais plus généreux.
Je dois d'abord
prendre soin
de certains aspects
de mes économies
avant de pouvoir
consacrer ces temps.
Je dois impérativement
travailler les dimanches.
À chaque fois
que les mondes
semblent rivalisés,
on a cette attitude
adultère.
Jacques 4.4,
adultère que vous êtes.
Mais savez-vous pas
que l'amitié du monde
est l'inimitié
contre Dieu?
Celui donc
qui veut être
ami du monde
sera un ennemi
de Dieu.
l'incapacité
de rester seul
avec ses propres pensées.
Cette addiction
à l'Instagram
pour ne pas
contempler la coupabilité,
réfléchir à la vie,
devenir des addicts
au travail,
aux occupations
pour ne pas s'arrêter
et réfléchir
sur la vie.
des fois,
ne pas être capable
de rester seul
avec Dieu
en traversant
des heures
de communion
avec Christ.
en premier lettre
des gens,
il nous dit,
bien sûr que ce n'est pas
une question
du monde
tel qu'est créé
par Dieu,
mais c'est les mondes
après la chute.
Au chapitre 5,
verset 19,
il dit,
nous savons
que nous
sommes des dieux
et que le monde
entier est sous
la puissance
du malin.
Le monde entier,
c'est-à-dire
dans la sphère
du malin
et les termes ici
veulent dire
être couché,
gésir.
C'est comme si
le monde était
rendu
à l'influence
et la domination
du malin.
Et bien sûr
que nous pouvons
réjouir
de certaines choses
que Dieu a créées
de manière correcte
et nous devons nous rappeler
que même les bonnes choses
de ces mondes
sont utilisées par Satan
pour prendre la place
des dieux dans nos vies.
Voilà pourquoi
on n'arrive pas
à se détacher
du monde.
Et donc,
si nous déclarons
avoir été crucifiés
pour les mondes
et avoir
les mondes
crucifiés pour nous,
si nous sommes
crucifiés pour les mondes,
ça veut dire
que les mondes,
ils perçoivent
à un moment donné
qui ne peuvent pas
nous sous-doyer.
Ils ne peuvent pas
nous dérouter
d'une voie d'intégrité,
d'obéissance,
de piété.
Peu importe
les menaces.
Et en même temps,
les mondes
sont crucifiés
pour nous.
C'est-à-dire
qu'il n'y a plus
d'attrait
qui puisse
me séduire
dans ces mondes.
Crucifiés,
c'est-à-dire
souffrir
un coup mortel.
N'est plus
avoir
les forces
pour aller
suivre ces mondes
ou les mondes
crucifiés,
n'est plus
avoir les forces
pour aller
nous séduire.
si ma vie
en tant que chrétien
n'est pas caractérisée
comme quelqu'un
qui est mort
pour le monde
et le monde
est mort pour nous,
je dois mettre
en question
l'authenticité
de mon salut,
au moins
la santé
de ma foi.
Je me rappelle
que quand
je m'appelais
au ministère,
j'avais
90%
des bourses
dans une faculté
de design
et il y avait
cette question
dans mon cœur.
Quand j'étais
appelé au ministère,
je savais
que j'allais
devoir entrer
au séminaire,
j'étais convaincu
de mon appel
mais il y avait
cette question
dans mon cœur,
si jamais
je me marie
avec une personne
dont les parents
ne sont pas chrétiens,
ça va être difficile
pour moi
d'éméler cette relation
sans avoir
un diplôme séculier.
Par la grâce
de Dieu,
mon pasteur
étant très sage,
il dit
David,
je suis tellement
convaincu
que tu vas
t'appeler ton plan
pour le ministère.
Un jour,
tu vas devoir
délaisser
les autres occupations
que tu auras.
Donc,
sois en paix.
Va aujourd'hui
là où Dieu
t'utilise les plus
et si tu dois
renoncer
ces dégrés
que tu les fasses.
Et je l'ai fait
avec la grâce
et l'assistance
des dieux.
Et les malheurs
que j'ai craignaient
m'est arrivé.
Les papas de Mayra
n'étaient pas chrétiens
et c'était dur.
Mais ce n'était pas
un choix difficile
à faire.
Comme a dit
Lloyd-Jones
parce qu'il a dû
renoncer sa carrière
très prometteuse
en tant que médecin,
il a dit
je n'ai rien renoncé.
Je considère
comme
les privilèges
les plus élevés
que quelqu'un
soit appelé
pour être un ministre
de l'Évangile
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Et nous sommes tous
des ambassadeurs,
pas qu'il y a
les pasteurs.
Mais c'est cette
caractéristique-là
dont l'apôtre Paul
est en train de présenter
comme en étant
la caractéristique
radicale
d'un imposteur,
d'un non-chrétien,
de quelqu'un
qui professe
la foi
avec ses lèvres
mais qui n'arrive pas
à manifester.
Vous voyez ?
Parabole et Terran,
ce sont des personnes
qui peuvent nous tromper
et nous-mêmes
pouvons nous tromper
pour longtemps.
Et c'est notamment
les moments
où les mondes
rivalisent
avec la croix
du Christ
que nous allons avoir
des évidences
récourantes.
Est-ce que nous allons
nous rétrécir
et embrasser
les mondes
ou est-ce que nous allons
être à la hauteur
et rénoncer
les mondes
pour embrasser
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Donc,
si d'un côté
une profession
des fois
étouffée
par l'amour du monde
est le signe
de la fausse foi,
la foi authentique
est une dévotion
exclusive
à la personne
et à l'œuvre
du Christ.
et c'est 14
pour ceux qui me concernent.
Donc,
attention,
l'insistance
de l'apôtre
Paul ici,
c'est de montrer
que ces contrastes
doivent être évidents.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'on va devoir
évaluer dans nos vies
et si c'est un peu
flu les choses,
c'est déjà dangereux.
Vous comprenez ?
Si nous sommes
très au calcul
de la manière
dont on se présente
dans la société,
on n'est pas
nous voulant
présenter
comme celui
qui sont
ceux
de l'escalde
de la croix.
C'était la crise
que Jean Calvin
a traversée
dans les moments
de la réforme.
Il y a eu
les mouvements
des mots
ici en France
et certaines personnes
accusées Calvin,
c'est facile pour lui
de réclamer
une profession
des fois si ouverte
car il est
en refuge,
en exil
à Genève.
Mais il n'y avait pas
qu'éjean Calvin
dans cette histoire.
Est-ce qu'on va
négliger
tous ces hommes,
toutes ces femmes
qui sont mortes
avec la conviction
qu'ils devraient
professer leur foi
ouvertement ?
Est-ce que la menace
de la persécution
peut justifier
une foi cachée ?
Si c'est comme ça
notamment
que nous trouvons
dans les pages
du Nouveau Testament
que l'Église a grandi
dans les premiers siècles,
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
on peut subir
au modèle
que nous avons
pour les chrétiens
en France ?
Nous sommes
libres
de les dire,
la Constitution
nous protège
et pourquoi
vivons-nous
si cachés
en tant que chrétiens
si nous sommes
notamment
l'espoir
des perdus ?
Les paramètres
n'ont jamais changé,
l'Église a toujours
prospéré,
elle continue
de prospérer
aujourd'hui,
là où les chrétiens
professent
les plus ouvertement
leur foi.
Ce n'est pas
une option pour nous,
ça n'a jamais été
une option pour nous.
Calvin,
il a forgé
cette expression
« les nicodéismes »
qui parlait notamment
de cette foi
des nicodèmes.
Nicodème,
dans un premier moment,
allait chercher Jésus
en cachette
pendant la nuit
pour poser ses questions.
Par contre,
là où
les moments
étaient les plus
au rendez-vous,
où il a dû réclamer
les corps du Christ
pour qu'il soit en sévélité,
où il a dû afficher
et prendre tous les risques
pour faire quelque chose
que c'était lui
qui pourrait faire,
il était à la hauteur.
Et donc,
pour ce qui me concerne,
c'est la manière
dont Paul est en train
de vivre,
c'est-à-dire,
voici comment
les vrais chrétiens vivent.
Pour ce qui me concerne,
un contraste
qui doit impérativement
être observable
et évident
dans nos vies.
Pour ce qui me concerne,
le monde est crucifié
pour moi,
moi,
je suis crucifié
pour le monde.
Pour ce qui me concerne,
attention,
car
jamais quelque chose
ne se passera
dans la surface,
dans la vie pratique,
si elle ne commence pas
au niveau du cœur,
au niveau de l'esprit,
au niveau de nos convictions.
Donc,
remarquez,
la phrase,
elle est remplie
d'affection.
Quant à moi,
loin de moi,
la pensée même,
vous êtes avec moi,
j'abrore,
j'abomine
l'idée même
de chercher
à me glorifier
pendant que les âmes
sont en train
de mourir
et partir vers l'enfer,
pendant ces moments
des batailles spirituelles
affreuses,
pendant que les mondes
sont plongés
dans les malins,
loin de moi
la pensée
de cacher
la croix du Christ.
Loin des mois
de me réjouir
à aucune autre chose
que dans la croix du Christ.
Et donc ici,
la leçon pour nous,
c'est que la question
est une dispute
des profondeurs du cœur,
de nos amours
les plus profonds.
Et donc pour lui,
il abrore même
la pensée
de se réjouir
à aucune autre chose
qui ne soit pas
le Christ lui-même.
Il abrore,
il répugne,
il a en horreur,
jusqu'à même
la pensée
de se glorifier
à une autre chose
qu'un Jésus-Christ.
Les vrais renoncements,
à nouveau,
ils sont faciles,
Philippiens chapitre 3.
Moi,
j'avais toutes ces étoiles-là,
mon curriculum,
mon historique,
une étoile montante,
l'apôtre Paul,
dans sa génération.
Succès selon les mondes.
Mais j'ai considéré
toutes les choses
comme de la perte,
de la boue,
par comparaison
à la sublimité
de la connaissance
que c'est en Jésus-Christ.
Et donc,
il dit,
loin des mains
de la pensée
de me glorifier
à autre chose
que la croix
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est qu'on commence
par la seigneurie
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Donc,
il dit,
me glorifier
d'autre chose
que la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ.
Soit le monde
est mon Seigneur,
soit moi-même
je suis mon Seigneur
en contrôlant
un peu la foi,
soit Christ est mon Seigneur.
Et si Christ est mon Seigneur
et il m'a dit,
allez donc,
faites les disciples
de toutes les nations,
s'ils ont persécuté
les maîtres,
bien sûr qu'ils vont
persécuter aussi
les disciples.
c'est la Seigneurie
du Christ
et pas
ma Seigneurie
sur les Christs
et sa croix.
C'est la Seigneurie
du Christ sur moi
et pas la Seigneurie
du monde sur moi.
C'est la Seigneurie
qui n'est pas
tout simplement
professée
et reconnue,
Christ est Seigneur,
mais c'est la Seigneurie
réalisée.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Il ne suffit pas
de dire
Christ est mon Seigneur
si dans ma vie pratique
Christ n'est pas mon Seigneur.
C'est quelque chose
de réel,
expérimental.
C'est intéressant.
Ce n'est même pas ici
la Seigneurie
du Jésus glorifié
car nous savons
qu'un jour
le Seigneur Jésus
viendra
et il jugera
les morts et vivants
et tous les genoux
sera pliés devant lui.
Par contre,
à ce jour-là,
ceux qui ne traitent pas
les Christs
déjà en tant que Seigneur
ne vont pas partir
avec lui.
Pour les chrétiens,
il est déjà
notre Seigneur.
Et qui est déjà
notre Seigneur ?
Le Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Ici,
c'est une référence
à Jésus des Nazarètes
ou un des dieux.
C'est pour ceux
que le Saint-Esprit
a ouvert les yeux
pour qu'on contemple
dans les Jésus
du Nazarètes,
dans son humiliation,
la gloire
du roi des rois,
du Fils des dieux.
Donc,
c'est totalement
incohérent
de dire
que nous avons reconnu
que Christ crucifié
était le vrai roi des rois,
Jésus des Nazarètes,
historique,
si nos vies
ne démontrent pas
une allégeance,
une réjouissance,
un débordement
des joies
et de parler
et de destifier
et d'obéir.
Car,
en contraste,
les judaïsants,
ils disaient
que Christ
était le Seigneur,
mais soit
c'était un Seigneur
qu'il pouvait désobéir,
soit
c'était,
car ils ne voulaient pas
la croix,
soit les Seigneurs
étaient un Seigneur lâche.
Qui aurait préféré
que ses disciples
évitent la croix ?
Vous voyez ?
Quel Seigneur
aurions-nous
si notre Seigneur
aurait préféré
qu'on évite la croix ?
Si les puritains
présentaient les Christ
comme étant
l'héros,
les héros
des héros,
pardon,
pourquoi ?
Notamment
car
il a traversé
la croix.
Qui honore
plus
les Christ ?
Qui démontre
plus sa puissance ?
Ceux qui,
dans la prospérité,
disent
« Voici,
mon roi
m'a donné tout ça »
ou ces hommes
et ces femmes
qui,
même lorsque
leur enfant
était présenté
pour essayer
de les dissuader,
de souffrir
les martyrs,
disaient
« Tiens bon
mon enfant
car le Seigneur
te donnera aussi
les forces
pour supporter cela. »
Polycar,
pourquoi tu me menaces
avec les feux
qui durent pendant
deux heures
mais les feux
de l'enfer,
tu l'ignores ?
Quelle foi
manifeste
le plus
la gloire
de notre Seigneur ?
La force
qu'il pourvoit ?
Son coup
le plus
héroïque,
celui du Christ
et celui
de la croix
et voilà
pourquoi
tous les premiers
chrétiens,
les premiers
martyrs
et la manière
dont l'Église
a été avancée
a été toujours
à travers
les sangs
des martyrs,
les témoignages
publics
courageux
des chrétiens.
Les martyrs
dont Paul
pourrait dire
« Où est
au mort
ta victoire ?
Où est
au mort
ton éguillon ? »
Et donc,
il faut
manifester
qu'il est
Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
et notre Seigneur.
Mais c'est intéressant,
il faut se glorifier
surtout
dans la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ.
De me glorifier
de la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ.
Ce n'est pas
cette croix
qu'il démontre
sa royauté
suprême
car il va
vaincre la mort
à travers
cette croix.
Mais ce n'est pas
cette croix
que le Seigneur
Jésus manifeste
la gloire
de sa personne
et la gloire
du Père.
Il n'y a aucun
endroit
dans l'histoire
de l'humanité
telle
qu'elle est
désignée
par Dieu
à part
possiblement
la gloire
future.
Et même là,
l'identité
de l'agneau
sacrifié
sera pour toujours
associée
à Christ.
Jésus-Christ.
Jésus lui-même
dans sa conviction
il dit au Père
Jean 10,
Personne
n'est hôte
ma vie
mais je la donne
de moi-même
j'ai le pouvoir
de la donner
et j'ai le pouvoir
de la reprendre
tel est l'ordre
que j'ai reçu
de mon Père.
Donc quelle gloire
cette croix
où nous voyons
la beauté
de la personne
du Christ
rien que par
la contemplation
de son œuvre.
Un innocent
volontaire
qui donne sa vie
qui délaisse
selon Philippien
sa gloire céleste
qui va traverser
l'incarnation
les tentations
sans avoir
aucune exigence
sur lui
qui pourrait
les motiver
à les faire.
C'est par grâce
par pure grâce
si on devrait
recevoir
ce qu'on méritait
ça serait
l'enfer
pour nous tous.
Et par pure grâce
ces terreaux
ces déploies
de ses prérogatives
et sa gloire divine
pour vivre
en tant qu'un simple
homme
souffrir l'humiliation
et jusqu'à
l'humiliation
de la mort des croix
et par là
Dieu prouvant
son amour
pour nous
en envoyant son Fils
lorsqu'on était
encore des ennemis
ou trouver
un Seigneur
plus glorieux
un Rédempteur
un Héros
une œuvre
plus glorieuse.
Mais ce n'est pas
que l'œuvre
du Christ
qui devient glorieuse
par la mention
de cette croix
c'est la personne
du Père
la personne du Fils
qui devient glorieuse.
Car Paul il dit
pour ce qui me concerne
c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce que cette œuvre
a abouti
par rapport
à ma vie
ce qui me concerne
ça m'a affranchi
de l'autopréservation
vous comprenez ?
Comment vous allez
aujourd'hui ?
Beaucoup mieux
qu'on mérite
car on méritait
l'enfer.
M'affranchissant
de l'autopréservation
ceux qui savent
qu'on a été
arrachés
de l'enfer
ne peuvent pas
trop s'éplendre
des difficultés
de cette vie.
M'affranchissant
par la croix
de l'enfer
que j'ai mérité
donc la tendance
à me préserver
c'est une tendance
qui essaie
de préserver
encore quelque chose
qui pourrait avoir
de la valeur
selon les mondes.
Mais nous
on a été crucifié
avec Christ
on a été humilié
par Christ.
Les Christ à la croix
est la représentation
de notre laideur
et de notre transgression.
On méritait l'enfer.
Notre réputation
c'était
l'abomination
de mon Dieu.
Par contre
par cette croix
je trouve
mon absolution
les Christ
qui va m'écréditer
son obéissance
parfaite
et qui va
m'unir
à Christ
pour toujours
à Dieu
mais réconcilier
pour toujours
à Dieu
en méfaisant
héritier
de tout l'univers.
Pourquoi
le monde
est crucifié
pour nous ?
Le monde
ne peut pas
avoir des attraits
comparables
à la gloire
qui nous attend.
Mais pas
qu'il y a la gloire
qui nous attend.
la personne
qui nous a été révélée
à la croix
car la gloire
du Père
et du Fils
sont par la croix
révélées
souprêmement.
L'heure est venue
où les fils
de l'homme
doivent être
glorifiés.
Quelle heure ?
Cette heure.
C'est l'heure
de la croix
du Seigneur Jésus.
Jésus-Christ
il est glorifié
souprêmement
par la manifestation
suprême
de la richesse
de sa gloire.
La lettre
de Paul aux Éphésiens
va exploiter
énormément
comment
les caractères
glorieux
sages
et souverains
de Dieu
vont se révéler.
Cette symétrie
divine
où un Dieu
de justice
va appliquer
la juste punition
de nos péchés
la condensation
de l'enfer
qu'on devrait
mériter
qui retombe
sur Christ
afin de manifester
par là
suprêmement
son amour.
Quelle est la mesure
du calcul
de l'amour
de Dieu
pour nous ?
C'est la croix
de son Fils.
L'objet
suprême
de son amour
l'être
le plus beau
de tout l'univers
l'objet
de la contemplation
de l'adoration
des anges
un étant
offert
pour nous
pour être
abominé
et crucifié
à notre place.
Les pères
sont glorifiés
car nous voyons
la symétrie
entre la justice
des dieux
et l'amour
la grâce
des dieux
et la miséricorde
combien nous
méritions
être
rabaissés
et envoyés
à l'enfer
et en même temps
la manière
dont Christ
nous va élever
aux régions célestes
en nous bénissant
de toutes sortes
de bénédictions
spirituelles.
Voilà pourquoi
en Colossien
à l'apôtre Paul
il dit
en 19
car il a plus à Dieu
de faire habiter
en lui
toute la plénitude
et de réconcilier
par lui
toutes choses
avec lui
tant celles
qui sont sur la terre
et celles
qui sont dans les cieux
en faisant la paix
par les sang
de sa croix.
C'est-à-dire
à la croix
nous sommes devant
la rédemption
de tout l'univers
qui sera glorifié
car Christ
est celui
en qui
toute la plénitude
des dieux
a habité.
Vous comprenez
les cosmos
complètement compris
dans l'œuvre
du Christ
notamment la croix.
Voilà pourquoi
Dieu nous dit
ou Christ nous dit
il a plus à votre
Père Céleste
de vous donner
son royaume.
Vendez vos biens
et faites des aumones.
Détachez-vous
les choses
de cette vie.
c'est la gloire
du Christ
qui est notamment
révélée
suprêmement la croix.
C'est la seule
raison
qui peut
déclencher
un affranchissement
tel du monde.
Faire que le monde
soit mort pour nous
et faire que nous
soyons mort pour le monde.
C'est quelque chose
c'est cette connaissance
expérimentale
et glorieuse du Christ
et la seule
connaissance
véritable
du salut
qui peut
nous crucifier
pour le monde
et crucifier
le monde pour nous.
Mais
si jamais
on a contemplé
le Christ
dans sa beauté
telle qu'est révélée
glorieusement
à la croix
non seulement
c'est la seule
manière
de nous crucifier
pour le monde
c'est inévitable
que le monde
ne soit pas
crucifié pour nous
et nous pour le monde.
Cette allégeance
elle découle
de cette contemplation
des glorieuses
du Christ crucifié.
Comme dit
Nehemiah Cox
dans ses sermons
fameux
qui est
les miels
découlants
de rochers
qu'est Christ
il dit le suivant
si jamais
vous avez appris
à connaître
véritablement
Jésus Christ
vous n'avez
découvert
en lui
qu'est pure grâce
qu'est justice
parfaite
qui abonde
infiniment
sur tout péché
et sur toute misère
humaine
c'est de lui
qui découle
continuellement
le de la grâce
qui peut vous
désaltérer
les miels
de la grâce
qui peut vous
rassasier
voilà pourquoi
l'apôtre Paul
il peut dire
qu'il est crucifié
pour le monde
c'est pas un refus
complet
à nouveau
des bonnes choses
de cette vie
que nous pouvons
réjouir avec Dieu
c'est d'avoir
une prise lâche
envers ces choses
mais la réalité
c'est que
c'est impossible
que les attraits
et les passions
de ce monde
puissent rivaliser
à la contemplation
de la beauté
du Christ crucifié
comparé à Christ
il n'y a plus d'attrait
nous sommes ici
devant la vraie liberté
la vraie liberté
des libertés
c'est là
où la tête du serpent
est écrasée
sous les pieds
des vrais chrétiens
c'est lorsque
les mondes
n'ont plus d'attrait
je me rappelle très bien
au moment de ma conversion
un ami à moi
qui a dit
on a perdu
un grand joueur
il a dit ça
par rapport
aux choses
qu'on faisait
dans les mondes
les sorties
les fêtes
etc
c'était clairement
par sa parole
par ses déclarations
il a perçu
qu'il n'y avait plus
d'attrait
après avoir insisté
que j'ai continué
de sortir avec eux
après avoir fait
des blagues
j'ai traversé la rue
il disait
Jésus
comme si ça pourrait
me faire de la honte
mon plus grand plaisir
c'était d'avoir
mon nom
ma vie
associée
au Christ crucifié
par qui le monde
est crucifié
pour moi
avant la conversion
on n'arrive pas
à dire non
pour le monde
après la conversion
rien
que le monde
puisse offrir
ne peut être comparable
à ceux qu'on a
reçu
et qu'on reçoit
du Christ crucifié
par qui le monde
est crucifié
pour moi
moi crucifié
pour le monde
et le monde
crucifié
pour moi
par qui
par Jésus seul
je suis crucifié
avec Christ
pour ces mondes
j'attends
les mondes futurs
et par qui
je suis crucifié
pour ces mondes
car les mondes
en contemplant
un vrai chrétien
à un moment donné
il ne peut faire
autre chose
que les martyriser
ils peuvent
perdre beaucoup d'efforts
pour les soudoyer
pour l'acheter
pour les séduire
mais à un moment donné
ils vont percevoir
!
que cette allégeance
à Christ
est réelle
et profonde
son plaisir
sa joie
est de faire avancer
les royaumes
ou d'être
avec Christ
qui est
incomparablement
mieux
le maximum
que les persécuteurs
peuvent faire
en chrétien
c'est de nous lancer
plutôt
dans la gloire
sur les bras
du Père
donc les chrétiens
les vrais chrétiens
il n'est pas
dans des disputes
très difficiles
lorsqu'ils doivent
renoncer
une fois
un de ces
hommes
importants
de certains ministères
m'a posé la question
mais comment ça se fait
qu'un ancien souffleur
qui a vécu toute sa vie
à la mer
à la plage
peut vivre
dans une région
si loin
de la mer
c'est vrai que ça me manque
j'ai beaucoup de plaisir
des opportunités
que j'ai
lorsque je reviens
à la mer
j'ai rigolé avec lui
j'ai dit
non je suis sûr
que quand je serai au paradis
je vais habiter
très proche de la plage
je l'ai dit
dans la Californie glorifiée
donc je vais
je vais reprendre
ces années là
et bien sûr
que Christ
sera ma plus grande passion
car il est déjà
ma plus grande passion
lui
son peuple
son église
la piété
c'est pas comme si
c'était difficile
pour nous
la vraie
renonce
les mondes
morts pour nous
c'est d'avoir
tellement de plaisir
dans la croix
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
que c'est facile
de dire non
à certaines choses
avant la conversion
difficile
dire non
après la conversion
la vraie conversion
les mondes
sont crucifiés
pour moi
moi je le suis
pour les mondes
ma fidélité
n'est pas à vendre
ces mondes
n'ont plus d'attrait
j'ai tu perdu
quand je me suis vu
avec Christ
crucifié
comme si j'étais
à l'enfer
j'ai tout gagné
en Christ
je suis déjà béni
dans les régions célestes
je n'ai plus rien
à perdre
à protéger
je n'ai plus rien
à promouvoir
de moi-même
mon allégeance
à Christ
notre allégeance
à mort